twenty-seven-year-old chelsea speed is
earning her master's degree in social
work but to make ends meet she's working
as a part-time cab driver in Washington
DC through a company called lyft but
Chelsea isn't like most DC taxi drivers
traditional cabbies have no way to buy
their own cars because each DC taxi is
required to have a special permit which
the city has stopped issuing so the only
way to get a vehicle is to rent one from
a handful of companies in the district
that already own large fleets of
permitted cabs Chelsea on the other hand
simply drives her own car since she
doesn't have a top light or a uniform
paint job she fixes a giant pink
moustache to her front grade to make a
car easy to identify for customers
traditional cabbies in DC don't just
need a permit for their cars they need
permits for themselves as well for years
the city had stopped minting new drivers
all together though recently it's
started again still aspiring cabbies
need to take a mandatory class and pass
a test before they can apply Chelsea on
the other hand saw an advertisement for
lyft online after a few hours of
training she was on the road if you have
a car and you have some time on your
hands which I do why not meet people in
the city and get paid for it customers
of traditional taxis generally held them
on the street Chelsea's customers find
her by opening lifts mobile app which
allows them to see her car in a tiny map
and hire her for a ride how's it going
good
lyft along with its competitors uber and
sidecar are remaking the taxi business
in cities all over the world while
kicking to the curb the bevy of useless
government rules and licensing
requirements that exist in almost all
major cities the local politicians and
government bureaucrats are fighting back
against this new model Washington DC
recently proposed new rules that would
force Chelsea to obtain a special
license to operate require that she have
her car inspected by the city every six
months and allow her to work no more
than 20 hours per week in Philadelphia
and New York City Austin and Minneapolis
Chelsea's car could be impounded if she
were caught driving in San Antonio she
might get arrested there's no logical
case against allowing lyft sidecar uber
to operate freely the fight is all about
protecting the existing taxi cartel in
fact passengers are safer riding with
Chelsea than in a regular cab because
traditional taxis don't provide their
customers with an easy way for
registering complaints with lyft
passengers get to rate their experience
after every ride and if drivers get
consistently lousy reviews the company
will fire them knowing that there's
going to be feedback from the customer
will cause suppliers to raise their
quality and so just sort of the fact
that in some sense you're being
monitored by the crowd this is a very
powerful form of sort of quality
assurance arun sander Rajan is a
professor at NYU who studies businesses
like lyft uber and sidecar which are
part of what's been dubbed the sharing
economy he says that the customer
back mechanisms built into these new
online platforms makes them largely
self-governing rather than needing a
government regulator to ensure
cleanliness of a particular sort of like
shared accommodation space you can rely
on the reputation system to enforce that
so a lot of the screening of prevention
is going to be done by the marketplace
itself another big advantage of these
businesses is that they don't require
any upfront investment models that tap
in to underutilized assets that already
exist these peer-to-peer models will
grow a lot more rapidly and have much
better economic fundamentals than
business models that require you to buy
assets and deploy them Airbnb has scaled
the idea of staying in someone else's
apartment for a short period of time
there's peer-to-peer car rental services
as carpooling comm in Europe which is a
city-to-city ride-sharing service and
they've got this massive transportation
network from different European cities
to other European cities and this has
been done without the creation of any
new infrastructure these businesses are
part of yet an even larger trend in
which new technologies including online
marketplaces 3d printers and virtual
cryptocurrencies are cutting out
middlemen and allowing individuals to
trade goods and services of all sorts
directly with each other these new
business models will remake our economy
that is unless the government stands in
the way
you